what's sure to be our most popular
trailer reaction of the year
right here we're going to make big
things out of
little things denzel time
john david might have tennant but denzel
he's got the little he's got the little
things
all those washing all those washington's
at the warner's
washington's raining down with the
lettuce yeah the lettuce and the malice
and the malex
all the most popular people clearly this
intro's the kind of intro you set up
to get the biggest trailer reaction of
the year right here
right here just before christmas this is
the holiday start this is the big rush
of content for you
this is this is one for us i know most
people do it seems like no one really
cares about this trailer
[Music]
films
[Music]
i'm
things probably changed a lot since you
left
you still got to catch them right yeah
all hands on deck approach to these
cases
guys are shocked if he stops he dies he
likes to drive he makes a decent car
maybe too
high he must really like my car
i do how's the trunk space
that's the bad guy yeah
[Music]
i love her yeah she is amazing
[Music]
he knew all the details but he wasn't
within 10 miles of the killing i love
how the morbius trailer had string music
too
this is going to be a more obvious
tie-in movie
oh
how's the trunk space
[Music]
i feel like that's the question to ask
yourself with him now though
i feel like he could very easily go
either way
thanks jimmy whoa wow your part is the
little things that
[Music]
get you caught whoa oh are you showing
way too much there in that trailer
i didn't just reveal what the twist is
i am curious it kind of feels like they
could have
it felt like they were a single hint
jared leto's the bad guy
but then you find out no he's not it's
denzel
at least that's what the trailer made it
look like right
at the end a little bit it looks like
he's about to reveal a
a punishing truth to rami malek that he
was not prepared for
ow seven vibe at the very end there
yeah i'm sure every comment says that
i'm just here to say what the people are
just go to the comments and say what
they're saying and make it sound like
it's our own first
first first second first
[Laughter]
no one cares if you're first will we
care i really like the way it's composed
yeah it does feel extremely
fincher-esque i find it funny how
david fincher seems to be such a
modern-day influence
on filmmakers even like the batman trip
you know you've seen this you do get a
lot of fincher vibes and i am a big
david fincher fan
more than seven i even get a little bit
more like zodiac or mine hunter's vibe
which are uh you know david fincher
i mean i thought of prisoners a little
bit during this tour especially in the
way that like in the advertising of that
movie like and not to spoil that movie
because you know it's not as clear and
cut
you know in its conclusions and whatnot
but that trailer makes it look like man
paul danno probably did it and this
trailer gave me the same conclusion with
yeah jared leto was like damn it
definitely looks like this guy
did it or else is gonna look like
incredibly suspicious up until they
spoil the ending that
maybe sam uh it just seems so apparent
the trailer is like it's chair letto
it's cheerleader then to show that
denzel moment and then to have like them
in the desert and the digging for bodies
is in another split personality twist or
something like that you know because it
seems like
denzel is kind of this small-town cop
hasn't been promoted
15 years hasn't been promoted probably
has a crazy history with
investigating violence and trying to
uncover like serial killers and such
perhaps when a little bit mad i mean
this is kind of what the the vibe i'm
getting from the trailer yeah like the
little things just seep in over time and
then eventually
boom i'm excited for the performances i
mean it's denzel
rami malik jared leto i don't know if
the trailers informed you but they're
academy award-winning actors
when did that happen i don't think the
trailers stated
what they are well they should if they
don't have any already
these guys are top-notch take it from me
and you know even with denzel
i'm going back to something that's a
little bit like the bone collector or
something you know
movies that are that that are not action
films his characters
the the one who will have the ultimate
descent didn't really get much of a vibe
for what rami malik's role is he does
seem like oh i'm a little bit more of
the professional guy who starts to
deteriorate through the case
jared leto i just can't tell if he's
doing a good job or a great
like is he doing great or he's a good
job or a great he's doing a great job or
is he
overdoing it you know there are times
we're just like
i don't know if i'm going to be able to
buy you or i'm going to be blown away by
what you're doing
it has become one of those actors to me
who sort of like
meme-ishly throws themselves into a role
and then yeah it almost comes down to
whoever's directing to
figure out how to make that work the
best because yeah i got that same
sense from this is like he's definitely
looks like he's having fun acting and
chewing on the scenery and it'll
come down to how well the movie fits
these three powerhouses together and i
mean
i'm hoping that maybe rami malek is sort
of the unsung hero because he looks like
he has to anchor
a lot of this with a more sort of poised
presence and in that sense he sort of
reminded me of like
the edmund xle character from la
confidential the guy pierce character
yes i was gonna say he's a little bit
more of like a film noir type of
character
yeah is the vibe i get with him yeah and
and that sort of
with his presence as well as just the
kind of setting of this it almost gave
it a sort of timeless vibe and that way
i do like the setting as well because
you know i don't know exactly what the
era is
but it looks sort of timeless in a in a
slight way anyway i mean it feels modern
day
yeah but it i get i do get what you're
saying like especially because it's
taking place in
what looks to be a small town yeah it's
not in some metropolis
yeah like small town major crime happens
and then big units come in
and then everything just starts
unfolding but yeah i mean i
can't get over that ending i don't know
if they gave like i'll be pretty upset
if
i watch the movie and i'm like i think i
gave it away
yeah because once they start to roll out
those reveals like the first hint you're
gonna be like ah damn it
yes because the mood and the tone was
already selling me
and the fact that you got these three
powerhouse actors in here was already
selling me and i already know that
they're going to go down this dark
spiral yeah like
i really feel like you could have just
even shown some of those visuals and not
had the dialogue in there
still let the music overlap to like this
christian telling you how to edit truth
let the crescendo just really
take it from mine take it from us we've
seen a lot of churches
and let it build so that way it's still
a mystery
as opposed to having you conclude like i
think denzel is the killer
yeah it looks cool looks good guys what
do you think about this little things
trailer do you think jared leto's gonna
do a
good job or a great job subscribe
click that notification bell hit the
like button we'll catch you guys soon
[Music]